what is this in here thinking the
unthinkable up until the weekend this
startup making sustainable Cosmetics
have been making plans for expansion
then for a moment it stared into the
abyss this was a basically contingency
planning what non-essential spend we're
going to have to cut if we couldn't
access any of our money life supplies
one of thousands of tech companies with
deposits at Silicon Valley Bank which
collapsed on Friday building a company
is honestly it's part of you and you put
so much like of your blood sweat you
know and tears into it and you've built
the T this team that all deeply care
about this mission of removing plastic
out of the bathroom you know it's
basically like losing a child frankly it
would have been it would have been
heartbreaking when that started to
become the reality after a frantic
weekend of negotiations at the bank of
England the bank was sold to HSBC for
all of one pound a relief not just for
Tech firms but in Westminster too
but this was a story which nearly ended
very differently
it's hard to describe the degree of
drama in the Bank of England over the
course of the weekend people working
through the night there were secret code
names for different parties and up until
the very last minute the Assumption
actually was that rather than getting
sold Silicon Valley Bank would have been
made insolvent that would have meant
that any deposits over 85 000 pounds
would not have been guaranteed and that
would have been a disaster for many
firms throughout the tech ecosystem
the story of the American Bank has ended
less well no buyer has yet been found
and Joe Biden's Administration stepped
in to ensure depositors wouldn't lose
money here are the highlights first all
customers who had deposits in these
Banks can rest assured and when I'm rest
assured they'll be protected and they'll
have access to their money as of today
second the management of these banks
will be fired if the bank is taken over
by FDIC the people running the bank
should not work there anymore the worry
is is a sign of more turbulence to come
The Regulators should take heed if you
like of the need to ensure that this
particular risk that we've seen
transpire a couple of times over the
over the past year of exposure to
Falling bond prices that that there are
not more institutions that are facing
that sort of risk we have the coolest
clients of any Bank anywhere Silicon
Valley Bank is no more it's clients on
both sides of the Atlantic live on our
clients invent the future but the
episode has raised fresh fears that in
an era of rising interest rates there
could be more drama yet to come at
Conway Sky News